ok c'est parti
moi j'ai un autre
[Musique]
feu avec cela c'est que tu peux faire
des crêpes
à l'école hôtelière de la montée régie
des étudiants étudiants en cuisine vont
tester des préparations du commerce pour
crêpe américaine communément appelée
pancakes
la quantité de préparation à pancakes
est impressionnante nous avons
répertorié plus d'une trentaine de
produits vendus dans les grandes chaînes
et en boutique des préparations nature
et aromatisées d'autres de blé entier ou
sans gluten au Babar végétalienne ou
encore avec supplément de protéines
[Musique]
c'est celle-ci
végétale moi je te conseille un lait
régulier puis 16 ans végétal
c'est quoi la différence entre une crêpe
et une pancake question pertinente on va
parler d'agent de pousser le pancake va
gonfler dû à un agent de pousser faudra
pas de bicarbonate de soude la crêpe
elle est mince il y a pas de bicarbonate
de soude donc la crêpe on peut la faire
sortir la rouler le pancake on le sauce
sont très aérés c'est bon c'est sûr
c'est meilleur c'est vraiment le style
pancake de traditionnel
très épais
vous savez le pancake c'est ce que je
fais le dimanche matin à ma famille
quand ça me tente pas de faire un
déjeuner justement c'est tellement
facile personnellement en étant chef je
considère que des œufs de la farine et
du lait c'est facile à trouver et ça se
fait rapidement je peux comprendre la
réalité des gens d'utiliser des mélanges
l'important c'est de cuisiner et voilà
appareil à pancakes aussi simple que ça
pour moi un produit qui est intéressant
va afficher une courte liste
d'ingrédients pas ou peu de sucre ajouté
et une teneur plus faible au niveau du
sodium
la nutritionniste Judit de bluchot a
fait une analyse de notre sélection des
préparations du commerce
dans les produits commerciaux souvent on
peut avoir des plus forteers en sodium
ou des grandes quantités de sucre
probablement que les fabricants vont
jouer là-dessus sur la teneur en sucre
et en sel pour aller modifier le goût
améliorer le goût de leur produit et
dans certains cas on va même retrouver
des grandes listes d'additifs qui vont
être ajoutées à nos produits ce qui
devient un peu moins intéressant par
rapport à notre recette maison qui sont
en fait des ingrédients tout simple
c'est mon premier drapeau rouge avant
même de regarder le tableau de valeur
nutritive on voit que toutes sortes de
choses que je connais pas vraiment quand
même une longue liste d'ingrédients
celle-ci au final le produit est
intéressant du côté santé c'est d'autres
choses ces trois produits là ces trois
familles de produits là se retrouvaient
parmi mes moins bons choix c'était en
fait parmi les produits qui renfermaient
le plus de sucre et de sodium par
portion la liste d'ingrédients elle est
plus longue à lire et on retrouve aussi
beaucoup d'additifs
[Musique]
dans un marché qui semble si compétitif
comment peut-on se démarquer c'est le
défi que ces données Marie Brossard
fondatrice de lulubel
comment se situe noum grâce à la
pandémie si je peux utiliser ce terme-là
le public se conscientise à acheter
local donc de ce côté-là ça nous aide
parce qu'on sait très bien que le
domaine de la pâtisserie dont les
pancakes c'est dominé par les compagnies
américaines le libel est distribué d'un
océan à l'autre donc non seulement au
Québec mais partout au Canada et nous
mélanges ont une liste d'ingrédients
très pur très naturelle on a du millet
on a du sorgho on a de la farine
d'avoine et on a également le sucre de
canne qui lui peut pas être local c'est
sûr nos produits sont tous sans gluten
alors ça attire de plus en plus une
clientèle non seulement les gens
étonnant au gluten mais les sportifs et
les gens qui ont pas envie d'avoir une
sensation de ballonnements ou de trop
grandes sociétés
d'autres produits sans gluten se sont
aussi démarqués lors de l'analyse
nutritionnelle
mais c'est intéressant mon premier soin
s'était porté vers le produit
l'angélique qui est très intéressant
pour la qualité des ingrédients pour la
présence de grains entiers il y a aucun
sucre ajouté dans le mélange qui est
vraiment très intéressant c'est arrivé
peu de fois le parmi l'analyse de
produits et on y retrouve aussi une
source de gras omega 3 donc encore ici
une belle façon d'aller chercher des
grains de bonne qualité dans notre
alimentation
la couleur est parfaite
mais ça m'étonne vraiment vu que c'est à
base de quinoa je pensais qu'elle aurait
été plus plat mais le beaucoup plus
gonflé que ce que je pense
celui-ci le mélange à pancake gogo
quinoa ne renferme aucun sucre ajouté
donc pour moi c'était un avantage
considérable et on retrouve vraiment des
ingrédients de belles qualités ça c'est
tout bien cuit le seul problème que
j'irais c'est quand j'ai goûté il y
avait un fort arrière goût je sais pas
si ça vient de la farine de quinoa mais
la texture est très belle le bob red
1000 est un produit très intéressant
pour une teneur plus élevée en fibres
donc ça peut être une belle façon
d'aller chercher plus grande proportion
de fibres au cours de notre repas le
matin
dans la catégorie préparation régulière
voici les choix à privilégier selon la
nutritionniste
j'ai beaucoup aimé ce produit-ci là pour
la qualité des ingrédients courte liste
d'ingrédients aussi puis le côté très
pratique on ajoute seulement du lait on
brosse et puis on peut verser le
directement dans la poêle corail ici au
niveau de la valeur nutritive se produit
si ce démarque pas par rapport aux
autres mais je trouvais vraiment que ça
ressemblait à une recette qu'on pourrait
faire maison avec nos ingrédients
directement de notre garde-manger
même si la préparation de Cora contient
un agent le vent le résultat s'apparente
plutôt à une crêpe le mélange apprenne
quelque chose
à un peu plus épaisse plus gonflé
quand on imagine une pancake on imagine
ça la couleur différente c'est que ça
cause c'est au gré anti ah oui il est
quand même super bien magnifique le top
userait le premier soir revient ici ou
menu bleu le choix du président agréanti
on retrouve des grilles entiers dans le
mélange une faible teneur en sucre
ajouté ce qui était quand même
intéressant une bonne teneur en fibres
et une teneur plus élevée en protéines
donc qui se démarque par rapport à
d'autres produits qu'est-ce que je
trouve intéressant aussi ça les
dégustant c'est le on sent les grains à
l'intérieur comme c'est pas juste comme
une purée c'est pas sucré mais avec des
fruits ça pourrait être intéressant
que vous choisissiez une préparation de
base ou à valeur ajoutée c'est la
garniture maison qui contrat pour
beaucoup dans la valeur nutritive totale
de votre pancake on peut rajouter du
yogourt des fruits et puis là
automatiquement on va aller chercher une
teneur plus élevée en protéines et en
fibres juste avec la diction
d'ingrédients qui sont nutritifs
[Musique]